[Musique]
tous les enfants de cette classe d'un
quartier d'istanbul longtemps comme un
l'exil la majorité d'entre eux partagent
aussi la perte d'un parent il tourne
toujours le monteur en seulement 12 6 et
7 en allemagne à bochum l'un d'eux un
communiqué il se retourne que celle de
sa probation
il ya toujours de nouvelles excuses
on attendait qu'elle était mineure entre
lui et ainsi ils sont originaires du
xingiang font partie de la minorité
musulmane ouïghoure red bull une de
leurs enseignantes habite istanbul
depuis plusieurs décennies les élèves
aient l'habitude de revenir souvent chez
elle au mécénat musique benameur canada
qui nous en empêche
choquer les âmes du qe2 trop comment je
suis boudou nous sommes écrasés par tout
connu est l'une des mieux en mieux son
rang des marques allemagne à l automne
au passé mystérieux les médiateurs de la
mairie
elle n'est plus jamais retournés en
chine elle a perdu tout contact avec sa
famille une séparation forcée qui lui
ronge l'existence sexuelle est en
quelque sorte nous sommes heureux qu'il
ait qu'elle fonderait ce moment se nomme
nous aurions des bordelais milieu que
quand le docteur deux camps sont au
milieu d'un hameau de quéhen soir à me
joindre
il demeurait autrefois au toutefois que
bastian travailliste phil shaw est
disponible en mairie
les défenseurs des droits estime que
plus d'un million de wii bourg et
d'autres minorités musulmanes du
xinjiang sont ou ont été détenus dans
des camps là bas il accuse la chine
d'avoir terrorisé de force des femmes et
imposer des travaux forcés est ce qu'il
en est abdul malik
à 11 ans il se retrouve seul en turquie
après une cavale qui l'a mené du
xinjiang à l'egypte avec les grands
parents puis ici en banlieue d'istanbul
le sort de certains appareils pas trop
souvent raconte le directeur de l'école
il doit leur annoncer de mauvaises
nouvelles quand ils ne sont pas mal
leurs parents ce retour souvent en
prison un lieu dont il a une
connaissance intime
en plus de ses études religieuses le
directeur avait développé une passion
pour la boxe
[Musique]
il n'avait que 16 ans quand il a été
écroué de son séjour il garde un
souvenir douloureux humiliant pour la
charia
depuis quelques mois c'est une scène
quotidienne devant le consulat chinois à
istanbul la turquie culturellement
proches des huit jours s'est toujours
montrée accueillante envers eux
mais il craint aujourd'hui d'être
sacrifiés au nom des intérêts
économiques et sanitaires d'un pays en
pleine crise 26 décembre dernier la
chine a ratifié un traité d'extradition
avec la turquie
un texte qui pourrait favoriser le
retour de huy gourc la chine accusent de
terrorisme
pas question que le traité sera expulsé
les ouigours assure le chef de la
diplomatie
mais la communauté ouïghoure elle n'est
pas rassuré la turquie a besoin de
liquidités et de vaccins la chine
possède les bus elle vient aussi souvent
qu'elle le peut pour réclamer la
libération des membres de sa famille
condamné à la prison pour soupçons
d'activités terroristes
son père sa mère et deux de ses frères
purge actuellement leur peine en chine
tiberi qui monsieur just want to be wild
et que ce chiffre cache pas ma main et
chisso hainan et chisso shy nom ghislain
des craintes and cheese faith un gros
crâne dieuze semaine dernière l'union
européenne
royaume uni les états unis et le canada
ont imposé des sanctions coordonnées
contre des dirigeants passés ou actuel
de la région du xinjiang pour violation
flagrante et systématique les droits de
la personne faire du canada américains
hollandais qui avait dans la salle on
brasse 70 appareils adaptés au sahara
tchoco tchoco avoir la cote chez jack
dia une demeure où l'on peut voir ça
howard belmiro c'est au fond la plus
grande angoisse qu ils partagent tous
qui dès leur reste-t-il et qui n'a
jamais disparu